That's That's the entire purpose of the Nicholas Diorio stream,
okay?
Yeah, I sure do love you. I sure do love you, Mr. Ethan Klein,
sir.
And she's just giggling at your existence. What the [__]
are you going to do now, Nick?
>> Dude, why is Gamma harvesting L's for no reason? Dude,
I can't believe I can't believe Connor put this in the video.
>> Woah, woah, woah. You think it's okay to do this?
All right, we need to do Twitter verses.
Nicholas Diorio. Discussions sparked online quickly with some
saying that this is Anisa mocking a minority's accents and others
saying this isn't offensive at all and rather just an accurate
impression the same way a Trump impression would be. Along with
all this, Nicholas Diorio got caught in the mix when Anisa started
making fun of him online along with him getting some backlash
online because he said the impression isn't not only offensive
but also bad with some interpreting this as Nick condemning the
impression or labeling it anti-Semitic. >> The whole debate
was sparked online and Nick responded to a lot of the backlash
on stream, but there's a lot to get into so let's just jump in.
Welcome to the internet's versus Anisa's Ela impression. It starts
when Yari posted the leftovers H3 subreddit Anisa's impersonation
of Ela. I'm a big fan of Nicholas Diorio. What can I say? You
do your research.
>> Saying that Nicholas Diorio does good research is so
funny to me. So, I I think they I do think they get along they
bond over the hate and that's, you know, good for us.
>> Dude. You done?
impression. There it is. I know. I said I know. I said I had
one. That's my That's my Ela impression. Who just hates on somebody
having a good time? She's just having She's just having a great
time. Who could look at this and hate I'll tell you who. People
who want to destroy all beauty in the world who see who've never
built anything beautiful themselves and just want to destroy
beauty because they're evil. That's who.
>> Sorry. I had a poker event that I did that at and it
did kill. No. Adrian.
>> Yeah, they both love Kino Casino,
Because they love all and anything deport deplorable and gross.
Sorry, Felt it Imp. I know you
I know you like it there, but
And glittering second replies, "God, Ethan's going to be so weird
and creepy in response for this one." And charm wonder says,
"A real mixed bag of vitriol misogyny with a touch of Islamophobia.
I fear we will get more
Bro, how do you If you're Anisa,
how that Dude, how did nobody snark at her for that?
That's like, "Bro, you are letting some dude named Felt it Imp,
like a phrase that's been popularized by Kino Casino, your most
vicious A-logs, you're just letting that guy sit around chatting?
And then you apologize to him for the the channel that shits
on you all the time?
I'm sorry, Felt it Imp. I I know you like them. Bro, what? >> Stupid
dumb [__] Anisa also posted the clip on the H3 all
that up subreddit with a caption, "It kills at parties." And
effective music replies, "We love making fun of the way foreigners
talk, don't we, folks?" And robot Nixon says, "The only time
I see Adam slip into full rage mode is when a woman with an accent
is criticizing him. I think Harley pointed it out once and after
that I've noticed it a few times." And pay wooden says, "Is there
a single thing that these people aren't hypocritical about? They're
so woke, but it's okay to mock an immigrant's accent as long
as it's Ela or the Iranian guy or someone else they dislike."
And my name is a Reddit talks replies, "In the same week, Anisa
made tons of fat jokes after having 10 plus years of body positive
takes to try and virtue signal. This re
Hold on. There's no way. There's no way Nicholas just took his
his takes from the H3 subreddit. There's no way that's like where
he's getting his opinions from, is it? That's not possible. These
must have been after Nicholas's stream. There's no way he would
like go and read the subreddit and take his takes directly from
this subreddit, right? Not possible. >> Eats hard constantly
Harley is the Epic Meal Time guy, yes. >> forgets what
position she needs to hold. Gatsufumin or tweets out this clip
with the caption, "The H3 H3 community is in an uproar over Anisa
Joma's anti-Semitic impersonation of Ela Klein, which they adamantly
insist sounds nothing like her." And I say, "You do your research."
Yeah. Got him. I I I was just confused. [laughter] Again, again.
With the recent Twitter issue I was I didn't know what she was
doing.
>> I know. I wouldn't have And by the way, I'm sure her
I don't think anybody Okay. You want You want to hear my impression
of I just Dude, what is she What is she doing like a like Yoda?
What is she doing like somebody else who sounds nothing like
Oh my god. >> Hey, my name is Anisa and I just Hey, you
[laughter] just did a silly voice. Me, Anisa.
Me, Anisa.
The cop around this may be the only thing that H is better than
the impression itself. The cop around this is just gold every
time I just having to watch them totally be fake and performative
trying to pretend that it sounds nothing like it. Oh my god,
it Ela, don't worry. It sounds nothing like [laughter] it. >> Dude,
I'm done. I hate you people. You literally didn't sound anything
like her. You just did a silly voice.
Yeah, we know it sounds like it. We know it sounds like it. And
Brino Blum says, "The Ela impression Sometimes I can't
Dude, god bless X8, okay?
God bless X8 putting the Willie Mac dumpstering
on this video. Hold on.
You're good with research. >> to see it. You love to see
it. >> Sometimes I can't tell if you're an Ethan hater
or a fan. Most of the time you just post his W's. And Gatsa replies,
"Is your Israeli wife also mentally impaired?" And Brino Blum
[laughter] says, "The
Do you love to see it? Ela impression was very spot on. Dragon
Harpoon quote tweets Gatsa's tweet by saying, "I didn't know
what an Israeli was when I first watched H3 H3 because I was
like 11. So, I just thought Ela Klein was or something." And
sleepy quote tweets Anisa by saying, "That sounds exactly like
Ela Klein." DJ Screwdriver tweets out this clip with the caption,
"Nicholas Diorio isn't impressed by Anisa Joma's impersonation
of Ela Klein." I'm a big fan of Nicholas Diorio. What can I say?
You do your
>> Saying that Nicholas Diorio does good research is so
funny to me. I do >> New dono sound. That will be a new
dono sound. I'm making it tomorrow. You done?
Wait, that was the Ela Klein impression?
Listen, all right? In the time that we've we've seen Ela Klein
impressions, I mean, that just doesn't That's not like a
I don't know. I know. >> Not only is that a That's not
like a Ela Klein impressions. I mean, that just doesn't That's
not like a tiered.
I don't know. Only is that offensive, it's also bad. Like it's
a bad impression. I said I had one. That's my That's my Ela impression.
That sounds like a character from What's What character is this
from
from from The Simpsons?
>> Well, I think it's Barney. It sounds like Barney from
Is it Barney? It was like the fat guy.
Oh, ELA WAIT, THIS ACTUALLY OH, THAT'S A GOOD ONE. She sounds
like the bear from The Cleveland Show. But you're saying Apu
cuz she's doing like a weird Everything she does sounds like
a weird Muslim accent, too. Her only time she has an accent is
doing a Muslim thing. fan of Nicholas Diorio. What can I >> Well, actually
Indian, maybe, too. You think he sounds like he's about to explain
why you need to join MetroPCS for your talk and text plan. With
full unlimited Yeah. So, it kind of is the bear. I mean, it's
not even a good impression. Nick is going to make so much freaking
money. Oh, no. What is this on the side that you've linked?
>> Dude, the Aiming Animations guy knew this dude better
than anyone else on the planet. Dude, that looks so bad. What
the What is that? [laughter] Dude, he looks like the dude engineer.
Oh my god. What?
Oh,
what in the world is happening?
IT GETS WORSE. IT GOT WORSE.
WHAT THE [__] How did it get worse? I like STOPPED
IT HERE.
IT GETS WORSE. WHAT IN THE
>> [__] WAY.
WAIT, oh [__] Hold on. I didn't mean to do that.
>> IT'S NOT ALIVE.
I KNOW. WHAT'S HAPPENING?
OH MY GOD, that is >> possibly the funniest
Dude, he's like He's so locked He's so LOCKED IN COMPLETELY.
>> WHAT'S HAPPENING?
Oh my god, that is >> possibly the funniest Here's normal.
Normal. Yes, human. Human. Human. >> Human. Human. Erect.
suspicious. Yeah. Wait, am I on the wrong way? Hold on.
>> That's Homo habilis right there. Homo
Homo habilis to Homo erectus.
It's like Why did someone at home catch
>> 7 hours and y'all had to pull this one this one frame.
So, it has to be from this, right?
Yeah. I I I think so. Oh, it's clearly from the supposed to be
a fan. Dude, he looks in real life like an Aiming Animations
like avatar. Like like something from an Aiming Aiming Animations
short. It's actually crazy. Like with the with the spinly arms
and everything. I had to pull this So crazy. [laughter] to be
a fan. Who did that? Yes. If you're not a If you're not a
You're not a snarker snark snark snark snark snark snark snark
Are you snarking? That was the famous Ela That
a muscle mass or even fat. All
>> And trust me, replies
If I
This is just an accurate impression of how Ela speaks.
Making an accent is the racist person.
of the south to be racist. She's not mocking Ela's accent.
accurate impression. It's not racist in my opinion. Besides,
isn't Anisa's dad a Muslim from Lebanon? Not that this impression
is racist. But I'd give her a bit of a pass with Middle Eastern
accents regardless.
I don't think that's right.
If a white person faked an Indian person's accent as a bit, it
would be judged as racist. Just because you justify it doesn't
make it less racist.
No, if you wanted to if you wanted to imitate
like Modi or something, you would probably imitate an Indian
accent. You couldn't do an a Modi imitation without putting the
accent on. It's doing an impression. She's not doing like an
over-the-top caricature accent, right? She's just trying to sound
like Ela Klein. Come on, man. Muslim doesn't mean you can fake
a Hebrew accent.
literally making an excuse for someone to do something racist.
Really testing the water on this. She's not mocking her accent,
she's mocking her by using her accents. And Phoenix replies,
by your logic, no one can do an impression of Ela without being
racist. This is classic Klein tactics. Redefine the rules to
maintain perpetual victim status. And Philly says, you shouldn't
be doing impressions of accents in the first place cuz it's racist.
Everyone knows this except you. No white person should be faking
Hebrew accents, Indian accents, or etc. This isn't redefining
a rule. Just what most socially normal people know not to do.
Chip Kibbling posts this clip on the I'm missing the ladder subreddits
Anisa admits to watching Nicholas Deorio in their spare time.
Anisa boasts about her Ela impression going
Apparently, iDubbz attempted to recreate
Not a dragon anymore. WHAT?
>> ANISA CAME in and immediately solved it. Is she like
an artist or something?
I feel like that's something an artist would notice is like how
the person's posed and why it can't look the same. But she came
in and was immediately like, "No, no, no, no, no, no, no, do
this, do this, do this."
>> Dude, posing him like an action figure. Uh just another
case of Anisa totally poppeting iDubbz. He can't even think for
himself. He can't even do like an Ethan impression without Anisa
telling him how to do it. loser. What a totally loser this guy
is. Goofy. Goofy. the impression was Anyone saying otherwise
is coping, lmao. I can't believe how viral that clip has gone.
It's been awesome. It proves to me that my irrelevance has been
a choice. It has been a choice. We we We watch Nicholas Deorio.
Why they got to say things like that? That's like a perfect way
to just sound like you're coping. They just feed people these
clips.
You don't have to talk about it. You just have like confidence.
coping over it. And it's so weird. So many of these like communities
you'd expect them to not have like weird allegiances in this
way. Like who the cares about Ela Klein? Like why would you be
going to bat for her?
Yeah, true. The dude with the war guy. Yeah. I think Nicholas
Deorio was like, "I don't understand. Sounds like Cleveland."
And it's like, yes. Yes, Ela sounds like Cleveland or the horse
from Cleveland or whatever the [__] he was saying.
I'm sorry.
Great observation. Yeah. Like tricking them into making fun of
[laughter] And Daddy Mirror Cat replies, so months ago they dropped
a video condemning xenophobia. Yet she is laughing about going
viral for mocking an immigrant woman's accent. That's certainly
a choice. And Sunny Bean says, Classic leftist though. If they
do something it's fine. If someone they hate does the exact same
thing, it is the worst action in the entire world. They are brain
dead. Layman says, they should not want to pick a fight with
Reviewer. Max and Bowblax come to mind who lost against Nick
badly. And Bio Electric Being says, And recently, Chud Logic.
Hell yeah, replies. Anisa has a giant and jealous hate boner
for Ela because unlike Anisa, Ela is able to find a ton of success
on her own and doesn't live in the shadow of Ethan. Whether you
like her or not, Ela is undoubtedly a successful businesswoman
who runs an extremely successful fashion brand which just branched
out into a new makeup line. She did all this while raising three
boys, too. Never had to shake her clothes off for money, either.
Ian and Anisa are such bitter losers and sound
Okay. Did she start with like a ton of seed capital because of
the business they ran?
Simply Chud Logic.
I don't know. Hold on. It's I mean
It seems like both Chud and Nicholas lost in that, to be honest,
Like Nicholas's average is way down. Chud's average is down as
well, I think.
So, I don't want to I don't want to say nobody lost there. It
seems like everybody lost, okay? When when everybody's too much
of a [__] to actually have a conversation in public,
everybody loses. Pathetic. Saying who cares about Ela Klein when
you're the washed-up INAF guy is wild. Shadow Army posts in the
clip of the I'm missing the ladder subreddits, Should Anisa's
impression of Ela Klein be considered as offensive or anti-Semitic?
I remember Nick said a while Dude, it's actually so wild that
these people call iDubbz the INAF guy when it's Ethan Klein.
I didn't realize how much Ethan Klein loved juicing the hard
R on his podcast
when he first started it. >> The H3 podcast is the hard
R podcast.
It's crazy.
a while back on stream that not only is it offensive, it's also
a bad impression. Personally, I'm quite conflicted on this position
as well. I do agree that her impression wasn't particularly good.
I disagree with the notion that her impression was offensive.
Should accents be considered offensive? After all, I remember
Nick saying multiple times that we should bring back accents
for comedic reasons. One such example being when lamenting that
Austin Show/Raj Patel was a forced to be a huge hypocrite by
putting on an Israeli All it is All it is is trying to do this
There's a huge double standard in the way white people are This
is like cope He cops [clears throat] out in the back. According
to your logic, Ela is fair game. Then OP replies to Nick by saying,
"Thanks for the clarification. Just want to make it clear that
I wasn't looking to hypocrisy hunt in any way. Which is why I
asked if I was missing something. When I saw your stream it sounded
like you just made a blanket statement that her accent was offensive
in general rather than the fact that her accent would be considered
offensive according to the values that she claims to hold. It
felt like the caveat was unclear, but then again, my memory was
vague, so I could have missed it. No, you didn't miss it at all.
Nick just didn't do it. Sleepy then tweets out the post of Nick
that we just read along with the clip we watched and captions
it by saying, Ultimate Review Guy Nicholas Deorio thinks accents/impressions
on stream is unethical and offensive. Glad to see Mr. U R is
thinking about optics now. And Auguiar of C replies, Objectively,
it is. If Ela was blocked Connor Connor got to do his roommate
like this, the former roommate. I don't know I don't know if
I could do this, Augie, if I could show this moment I can't see
a man what you're doing. That would be hilarious because it's
offensive. I don't think Nick is suddenly disavowing offensive
humor. It's obviously a hypocrisy argument because Anisa is a
woke scolding leftist. And Jaystalker replies, is there more
to the clip that's cut off that makes it clearly a hypocrisy
argument? Hey!
I didn't think I was going to make it this time.
Let's go! Although nobody literally
I'm I'm serious. Nobody
is actually
going to respond to this. Confusing opinion says the Reddit comment.
And Jaystalker says, so after the fact he said something different.
And Video Gamer replies, why do you retards think this is a good
comment? The Reddit comment isn't contradicting anything he said
in the clip. It just clarifies his position which he clearly
had at the time of stream as he's held the same That person responded
to me. I didn't see that.
No, it's a it's actually different. meaningfully different. They
are semantically different. If you don't continue on with your
thought at all, being offensive means the person is
Am I the only person who speaks English?
What the
Freddy Woods replies to Augie by saying, At what point did she
do a stereotypical voice, lmao? She just makes fun of Ela's voice
and what she actually says. And Augie replies, Making fun of
accents is usually something people find offensive. I don't care
cuz I'm racist, but that's how most people see it. Pointing out
that something is offensive doesn't mean you find it problematic.
And Freddy replies, it's not making fun of accents. It's just
her voice. Ela has no discernible accent. It's just her slow
drawl being made fun of. Ronald replies to Augie by saying, "Nick
did a Chinese accent like 2 minutes after this. So, the offensive
part clearly wasn't even his main argument. And Sanchez replies,
it's the fact she's supposed to be an uber woke leftist who hates
the till it's a joke. Tippetoppa replies to Augie by saying,
He's trying to imply it's against the rules. Doing an impression
of Ela is apparently not supposed to be allowed. And Sanchez
says, no, because he does an accent after. Anisa is supposed
to be the super anti-racist. She shouldn't be faking Hebrew accents.
And Tippetoppa says, yep. Doing an Ela accent is anti-Semitic.
Anti-Semitic people deserve to be gassed. And Sanchez replies,
dude, what are you yapping about? It's just funny an uber woke
Twitter like Anisa reaches into her Irish ancestors' blood to
do the Hebrew
This is none of that was there. None of that was there and these
people are embarrassing.
Okay? Nick is doing his minstrel show for the H3 viewers, okay?
That's what he's doing.
All of Ethan's enemies are bad. That's that's the entire purpose
of the Nicholas Deorio stream, okay?
That's what we're all mocking and all of you can cope and pretend
he's some independent actor when we all know he's not, okay?
Yeah, I sure do love you. I sure do love you, Mr. Ethan Klein,
sir.
That's all it is. And Tippetoppa says, you are an uber woke scolder.
Oh my god, she did a funny impression of Ela while shaming the
fat one. She's evil. Kill her. Anisa handed you an L. Take it.
It's bound to happen when you're on Team Ethan and fans. You're
on the same level as her. Sorry, loser. And Sanchez replies,
that literally isn't what I said, dude. I said she's a woke scolder
of other people but fakes Hebrew and Iranian accents. Does he
keep saying dude? And do Not only did you fail to read, you just
announced it something to yourself in a delusion. And Tippetoppa
Dude, he keeps saying dude. Bread man, you ain't slick. It's
very obvious you're conjuring up that she's anti-Semitic because
you can't handle she did a funny impression mocking Ela. Instead
of just acknowledging it, you have to pretend that she broke
some gay rule. Hey, Anisa sucks. True. But it was funny. And
Sanchez replies, dude is ironic. Yeah, she faked a Hebrew accent.
This is Anisa's gay rule, dude. I don't give a [__]
they mocked Horse Face Klein. Point is that Anisa is a woke scolder
doing edgy bits. Bow. There's no How does that sound Israeli?
It doesn't sound Israeli. Sleepy posts by saying, Crazy that
this is Nick Deorio's take now when him, Keemstar, and Tommy
C would mock Ela's accent all the time when they were calling
her a horse a couple years back. And Marco Leto replies, proof.
And Bowblax attaches this clip username who says, "I don't know
why I made Ela French." But no, did you hear Tommy do the Ela
Klein voice and say like that? He did that today. You guys did
this tonight. Tommy gets on there and goes, Dude, Israeli accents
do sound French to me. Keemstar. So, maybe you should stop being
a little bit nicer. That's the way it works. Tommy is Yeah, we're
going to get Tommy to start doing Tommy has a really good I still
don't understand why Tommy's Israeli voice is racist. I don't
get it. Okay. It's funny to me. I was in the military and now
I am wondering why Keemstar is so mean to people. Anisa goes
live and addresses some of this along with talking about Nick
Deorio. And Legaspi NC posts this clip from her stream with the
caption, Today, Anisa ranted about Nick Deorio, lol. So, there's
this creature um named Nicholas Deorio. And Nicholas Deorio,
okay? is uh someone who posts videos of him celebrating his birthday
alone. Which again, not a problem. But if if you're you know,
That is just the cake gif, isn't it?
Uh it is just the cake gif. I don't know, maybe friends and family
are sufficient. At least have a dog or a cat or something. Uh
but anyways, he is a commentary one of these commentary slop
guys. Um but he has a segment called the ultimate review where
he reviews uh rape cases and decides whether or not um the woman
is lying.
So, and that's by the way who Ethan and Ela watch and enjoy.
They think he has really good research. I quoted directly from
Ela with that. So, um that's that's who that is. Ela said yeah,
Ela said that he's her favorite and uh she donates to this uh
individual. And if you look at him uh like a picture of him,
he doesn't like stream himself, uh which I after seeing what
he looks like, I get. Uh because he looks like he should be holding
a giant
uh oversized lollipop at all times. Oh, [__] And
I you know, hey, I get it. I think he also lied about having
a girlfriend and then got outed for lying. And he's talked about
us for a long time. Dude, he calls it he calls it the friend
zone
Right? He That's what he repeatedly calls it is the friend zone
lie.
It's like, are we Is it a lie?
I don't think Oh god. Yeah, I can't believe you put the uh the
lollipop picture in there. That was just fun. Uh [__]
I feel bad.
Oh, well. Oh, well. Uh
What What is the lie? Where's Has anyone explained what the friend
zone lie was? Because I Trust me, I believe personally
that he didn't want his relationship
And that's like some part of that is he just tries to pretend
that that person was like whatever. I think that's what it was,
right?
Yeah, but I think it was his girlfriend though. I do think it
was his
I But I also think that's like his long-term girlfriend that
he's known forever and he probably doesn't want her identity
known online at all, right?
Which like I understand why he doesn't want that, okay? But Um
and I didn't really talk about him one because I'm not really
online, but two I I also just feel bad for him. I think out of
all the Slot Tubers, I feel the worst for him
I Yeah, not good. Even Well, she did say they weren't dating.
But I The girl said they weren't dating. I do think that was
his girlfriend though or became his girlfriend or >> pictures
of him, it looks like he's not comfortable wearing his own skin.
So, I you know, but we are done being nice, aren't we, chat?
He's making bank off of you. It's He's making bank off of Ethan
and Ela. I There's quite the talent of um people in that world
finding someone who's just a little bit dumber
than you. So, you can like prey on them, but Nicholas DeOrio
is getting eaten by his own. I heard that he's becoming a lolcow
himself. So, and that's the fate, isn't
of those creatures?
And Nick DeOrio replies, it's so funny. Sleepy then tweets out
this sleepy caption, "Nicholas DeOrio can talk about Anisa and
I's relationship, but never bring up him getting publicly friend
zoned on Twitter." Toka, when did the tears come out of my eyes?
I was crying. >> When did the tears come out of your eyes?
Probably when that girl said she wasn't your girlfriend on that
post. That was the Also, by the way, this clip stand-alone is
incredibly [__] embarrassing, right? Regardless of
the status that was commented on, regardless of who that person
is to Nick, the response in this debate or whatever it is is
[__] embarrassing. >> the shadiest I've ever
seen? What girl said she wasn't my girlfriend? >> When you
posted a picture of you holding somebody's hand, you just trying
to be vague about it and then they're like, "You have a girlfriend?"
And the girl's like, "No, no, no, he's my best friend." >> You
have no idea what you're talking about. That's hilarious. >> That
was funny as [__] Okay, so that didn't happen, Nick.
Nick, did that happen or not? Yeah, it absolutely happened. You
posted a vague picture of you holding somebody's hand. They're
like, "Some And then do you have a girlfriend?" She's like, "No,
no, no, he's my best friend. He's not my >> talking about
my personal life on here. I don't >> your personal life.
It's a tweet you made. It's a tweet you made, Nick. Nick, it's
a tweet you made. That's not your Do not Tweet you made. It's
not your personal life. It's a tweet. Not your personal life,
dork. Oh, wow. You think it's cool to talk about like I I Wow,
wow, wow. You think it's okay to do this? Wow, wow, wow. He loves
doing that one, doesn't he? Wow, wow, wow.
>> don't name people like this specifically cuz I keep
that part of my life very off the internet.
You'd be pissed. Also, you'd be pissed about somebody bringing
a tweet up that he made.
He tweeted something publicly.
What do you mean?
You can't be angry when somebody references something you tweeted
publicly intentionally. You intentionally published this. There's
no You have no right to be angry about somebody bringing it up.
No, you don't. You tried to post it and It's not It's not your
personal life. You put it on Twitter. Look cool, and you didn't
look cool. It was her idea. Like it's not By the way, it's not
like she posted it and accidentally revealed anything. It's It's
nothing like that. He put the picture on Twitter.
He introduced it to the public zeitgeist
to make the post in the first place. I told him I'm sure it was.
She did. That's none of your [__] business. Then
why'd you post it on Twitter, Nick? >> going along in this
argument. It's none of my business. Why is it up there, Nick?
Why'd you post it if it's none of anybody's looking into people's
personal lives and How IS THIS YOUR PERSONAL LIFE, NICK? WHY
DID YOU POST IT ON DEBATE, TOKA? Because it's funny. Remember?
It's about things that are funny. We're debating. We're debating,
Nick. Is that what's happening? Oh, did Nick uh >> The
URL world DeOrio replies, "Hm, I don't think you can compare
making a content come video that was so bad it led to the implosion
of a multi-million dollar charity boxing event or getting friend
zoned over 6 years ago. Like why even waste your time making
this post?" And Proxy replies in his hug box, attaching a message
Nick DeOrio sent to his Discord where SimpMan asks, "I wake up
and see a bunch of anti-DeOrio posts. The [__] happened?"
And Nicholas says, "People tried twisting the comment I made
about Anisa's Ela impression. And when that didn't land, the
usual suspects just started kicking and screaming, pulling up
the classic 'he's fat' and the fake friend zone thing from 6
years ago." And then Anisa Jomha Kouchi joins the club by saying,
"Wait,
I think we were just like laughing about We're not just broadly
laughing about
like Anisa joining in the snarking. That's what it felt like
to me. "Oh, look, Anisa's getting in on it. It's so funny, man.
It's so funny. It's like we're all We're all just getting in
on >> This is so embarrassing. Wow. And Floyd says, "The
fact that Toka so up Nick makes this 10 times funnier." And Anisa
replies, "I will be honest, I don't know what a Toka saw is,
but I imagine if they're in a Discord call with you doing the
work, kid, that can't be good." And Felted Emp replies to Anisa
by saying, "My liege, thou post an ancient clip from one of the
lowest dirtiest sector of rats to ever be, but thou denies the
hot fresh Ralph content. What injustice may this be? It is not
my place to question her royal majesty. So, I humbly beg forgiveness,
but this perplexes me so much, oh my queen." And Anisa replies,
"Felted Emp, I'm sorry. I don't know who anyone in this clip/poster
is, nor how new/old it is. I'm a victim to my timeline." Gamma
tweets out a picture of Nicholas DeOrio's Instagram and captions
it, "And Nicholas DeOrio has now privated his Instagram, which
was once public." And Jackbox replies, "It's been private for
months." And Gamma says, "No, it hasn't, lol." And Jackbox says,
"It has been private since at least the turkey Tom drama." And
Gamma says, "Then it hasn't been months." And Jack says, "It
has been over 2 months since the drama started." And Gamma says,
"Erm, it's actually been like a month and a week or so." And
Jackbox says, "Started." And Gamma says, "It still has been less
than 2 months." And Jackbox replies, "Incorrect." showing that
Sacramento made her original post on January 4th.
>> Dude, why Gamma harvesting L's for no reason. And these
posts were from March 16th. And Gamma replies, "Okay, but you
only got me by 4 or 5 days."
>> Why don't just Bro, what the His reply is, "I'm lost
as [__] Is there anything significant going on or
are we trying to conjure something into existence through wishful
thinking alone?" And Gamma replies, "Nicholas DeOrio is to commentary
what Baby No Money is to music." And Ropes of says, "Didn't answer
the question a word." And Gamma says, "I did answer the question.
It's called people are becoming conscious of the reality that
DeOrio is a [__] drooling [__] who's
just as annoying and as Anisa and Ropes
Honestly, you kind of got to stop You look bad when you keep
arguing this despite getting all those timelines wrong and [__]
You kind of look stupid. >> replies, "Evident by a private
account. Frankly, the two would be smarter and less annoying
if they followed his step and privated too." And Gamma replies,
"The private account is a result of him tucking his head between
his shoulders as a product of getting rammed by the turkey Tom
drama. If you're not tapped in, just say so." And Simon
To be honest, I do think the privating of the Instagram is probably
because
they were pointed to somebody in his personal life who he was
dating. I'm guessing he was concerned about people going back
through his Instagram to figure out who that person was, right?
If he had it public before.
That's what I would guess. >> The private account is a
result of him tucking his head between his shoulders of getting
rammed by the turkey Tom drama. If you're not tapped in, just
say so. Like it's It's not even that that weird because somebody
was talking about trying to figure out who he like his girlfriend
was. I think cuz she would know who Tom cheated with or something.
I don't know. Simon Says Ranger replies to Gamma's post by saying,
"And?" And Gamma replies, "It means little piggy is scared of
the big bad wolf and locked himself in his little echo chamber."
And Simon says, "What happened? Who is the wolf?" And the Funny
Juan replies, "I think this gay [__] is larping as
a big bad wolf." Anisa Kouchi tweets Gamma's post with this picture
of Nick DeOrio and the caption, "I guess he didn't like people
pointing out that he looks like a troll with arms." And JaySocker
replies to this picture of Nick DeOrio edited to have a giant
lollipop. Yola replies to Anisa by saying, "It's all I Dude,
I just
I just thought it was funny. I just thought it was funny.
I'm not going to be the person I shouldn't snark on people's
I shouldn't snark on other commentators' looks, >> Always
the guys that look I do that with random people on stream. Doing
that to Nick probably out of pocket, okay? And Anisa says, "It's
so loud about it, It was funny though. >> And her funny
post is this picture of Anisa in the caption, "You look like
his cousin." The girl with a microphone screenshots Anisa's post
and captions it by saying, "Oh, wow. More fatphobia from a moral
authority, Anisa Jomha. What a cool and interesting person she
is." And Mr. Laugh replies, "We all know Nick is overweight.
I know she cannot possibly understand this, but we listen because
he is funny and entertaining. They never left their hatred behind.
They just hid it better." And girl with a microphone replies,
"Yeah, but you don't get it. Fat people aren't allowed to have
opinions." And Andrew Fat people are obviously allowed to have
opinions. What the replies to girl with a microphone by saying,
"The point is that he went after Anisa's appearance on stream.
After that, it is accepted for her to do the same. This gay Look
at this left as being fat phobic is so pathetic within this context."
And the girl replies, "You paid for a blue check mark. I think
that's gay." And Andrew says, "You must not really like Nick
Adams." attaching a screenshot showing Nick has a blue check
mark. The Bastard Squirtle replies, Okay, that random guy won.
Let's go. >> gay. And Andrew says, "You
must not really [laughter] like Nick Adams." attaching a screenshot
showing Nick has a blue check mark. The Bastard Squirtle replies
with these pictures in the caption, "I asked the Grok to show
what Anisa would look like in 10 years." showing Anisa with her
head shaved and then this photo. A sure contribution posts this
interaction on the left for stage 3 separately with the caption,
"Nicole DeOrio crying about people being mean to Nick DeOrio,
Rick Review Guy." And they post her Twitter post along with this
image here, matching a picture of girl with a microphone and
Nick DeOrio, and showing compared [laughter] faces in 84% match.
And then they show this edited photo of Nick and girl with a
microphone half squatted. And Trick Reference says, "Ethan Klein
is the most fat phobic dude ever." Dude, Connor knows what he's
doing, okay? X8 knows exactly what he's doing when he makes this
video.
He knows exactly what he's doing, all right? I'm sure some people
who support Nick had bangers here, and he's making it look like
they're all just slobbering
Okay? Connor, you know what you're [__] doing. You
know exactly what you're doing with this video. >> You're
live. How are they even trying to make this argument? I saw H3
fans within the last month claim that Anisa couldn't have had
an eating disorder because she's not thin enough. Excuse me for
not taking their cries of fatphobia seriously." And Ibérico Ham
says, "Are these people dumb or just stupid? They don't understand
how anything works, like at all. No wonder they fall into cults
so easily." Lurk or says, "Ela hates fat people. It's why Ethan
is on his Olympic and storing prescription meds. It's also very
odd, but not surprising, that she's defending a racist chad who
hosts reviews, laughing at essays on women. Not a girl's girl.
She's a pick me for incels." And I see Marion Berry replies,
"And still doesn't have a man, I think, lol." And Captain King
Pow says, "Microphone girl is a lesbian." Anisa then replies
to girl with a microphone's post by quote tweeting it and saying,
"There are many beautiful fat people who love their bodies. He
isn't one of them, and neither are you with that bun you choose
to wear every day. Bro's ankles look like they've been pumped
with the salt, and he needs a lymphatic drainage stat. He looks
like he has a rotation of goods that are all beige in color.
That's not my problem. Micronutrients matter. Love your body.
Take a multivitamin. Eat auto-corrected foods to goods. Thanks
for that, iPhone. Tate was taken her place and he said by saying,
"You are such a mean and hateful [__] Oh my
Wait, is that a hate post or
Does this person like Anisa or hate
Does this person like Anisa or hate I actually can't tell.
Are these Man, I must have missed the I guess I just missed the
whole era where Anisa and iDubbbz got really into all this stuff.
I kind of thought they were
Wasn't E- Wasn't Ethan's whole thing he was mad about?
The fact that they stayed out that they didn't involve themselves?
Wasn't that what he's actually upset about in the first place?
You guys refused to come to my aid. You refused to step in and
say something bad was
Wasn't it their lack of willingness to insert themselves that
actually was what they were getting pissed out
You sounded like Anisa when you yawned, J Talk. Wow.
Thank you. I'm hearing this I'm hearing this for the first time.
Didn't know that. When you really should be concerned with getting
an infection from never washing your ass. Go take a shower, nasty
bitter Mike replied to Anisa by saying, "Anisa in her mean girl
bully era, and honestly I don't mind it. Hot take, but I think
if you're hot and skinny enough, you're allowed to be a bully
to a certain degree. She's done a lot of work to look the way
she does. So, she kind of has some authority on the subject of
healthy bodies." Leslie Nessu says, "Me when I'm a pathetic ass
[__] with no substantial criticism, so I just resort
to being fat-phobic and bullying people based on appearances
even though I'm covered in tattoos and my husband looks like
he crawled out of Dobbs' ass." And girl with a microphone screenshots
Anisa's post and captions it by saying, "One, cool insult about
my hair from your favorite snark subreddits. I love my [__]
ass bun. Two, Anisa Jomha is deciding which fat people are Okay.
It's literally like the one defining thing If she didn't want
to call you a disgusting fat pig, the bun is like the one thing
you could insult. So, like I
How is that What is that have to do with snark? The snarkers
are to going in on your bun?
I I don't know what what of the material is there there. Line
up, tubbos.
Three, I have yet to say a single thing about your looks because
I'm not mentally stunted at 13." And Harley Morenstein replies,
"Wow, she is so Jomha says replies to the girl with a microphone
by saying, "I am nearly as fat as you. Do you think Ela, who
fat-shamed her own husband is so relentlessly on air he became
a running skeleton, hasn't said worse about you? P.S. You should
not be happy with that matted rat's nest. I would put money on
mold being in there." And girl with a microphone replies, "Oof,
this is so sad." She also makes a follow-up post to separately
saying, "A grown woman insulting another woman's hair and body
in 2026 is so [__] rotten and stupid. Like how miserable
are you, girl?" And Dish replies to this post from girl with
a microphone in the caption, "Yeah, imagine commenting on someone's
looks in 2026, right?" Then it's her quote
"Anyone ever notice the these people only laugh when they're
being ugly and
That's like saying the rhetoric is ugly. They're saying the behavior
is ugly. That's a bad tweet. That's a bad tweet.
When they're being ugly and cruel, this is this is talking about
the speech being ugly, not Anisa being ugly." And post from a
few days ago where she said, "Anyone else ever notice only laugh
when they're being ugly and cruel?" And the girl with a microphone
replies, "Oh no, guys, he can't read." And Dish says, "Glad I
got your attention. Can you address your co-host starring in
a transphobic music video? Hope you can address that in your
aftershow instead of covering week-old celebrity news. Thanks."
Okay, Mammoth also posted on the H3H3 Productions subreddit the
interaction of Anisa and captions it by saying, "But he's not
Frogan, so it's okay. He looks like he showers, has clean hair,
brushes his teeth, and doesn't have rancid mango breath and trailer
park tattoos. I would just say so, of course he's in her type,
but then again neither is Ian. Also, the aunt should be tending
to her caretaker duties by making sure the dragon doesn't actually
drown in the tub or something." And aggressive expert replies,
"It's going to kill her that this guy is hitting home run after
home run every day because she can't help but embarrass herself
online."
Mango breath? I've no idea, man. He's making more money than
her online and at his day job. I would be coping and seething,
too." And Mikey Roberto says, "And never forget that there was
a time, maybe still applies, when Nick was making more money
from Twitch than iDubbbz, despite him never even going live,
just from people subbing to his inactive account as a joke."
Spooge McDuck says, "DeOro is a legitimately talented streamer.
He is quick-witted, speaks fast yet clearly, is funny and charismatic,
and most of all I believe what he is saying. I don't agree with
him on everything and don't appreciate some of his points, but
I would much rather hang with him than because I would have a
much better time with him than Ian and Anisa. Based on what I
I don't know if that's true. I'm trying to think of who would
be a better hang. I actually don't know. Man, I have I actually
have no idea who would be better to hang out with cuz I get the
feeling that Ian and Anisa must must drop this [__]
a lot when you're hanging out in private.
Nick could be funny.
I don't know.
Maybe it depends on what you're doing. I've seen from him he
seems to listen to reasonable arguments and can change his mind
on things, which puts him miles ahead of Ian and Anisa." And
Tofel replies, "I definitely agree. Meanwhile, iDubbbz' streams
are by their nature pretty boring. I wonder why Nick gets more
viewers than iDubbbz." And Tolerant Drama Retiree attaches a
thread of comments from the thread we were just on on the clip
the live subreddit captioning it, "The H3 girlies are all over
Nick less." And there's multiple comments here. It starts with
a loving Anisa saying, "Okay, listen. Dude, this is so weird.
This is so weird. I've always thought he's kind of hot and is
Dude, I can't believe I can't believe Connor put this in the
video.
Connor is like a covert snarker, okay? I see I see what XATE's
doing here. That's the the creator That's the guy who makes the
videos, by the way. He's like totally a covert snarker, like
100%.
Super obvious, man." And Anomic says, "People really underestimate
how being happy is a factor in their attractiveness. Most people
don't want to be around miserable people. So, when you see someone
smiling and laughing, it's a way more attractive than crying
on a stream." And Felicity Foxen says, "This is genuinely so
true. I don't know if any This is not true. This is just not
true. I'm sorry. This is cope.
This is like This is like four out of 10 cope, okay?
I'm sorry. If you
People don't gen- genuinely like don't I It's total cope. I don't
know what else to say. There can be people who are like really
happy and like bright and
but if you're like if you're like 100 lb overweight, that's not
going to matter, okay?
Fat people, by and large, are the happiest people you'll ever
know cuz they have to be cuz otherwise people would want nothing
to do with them whatsoever. But they still don't want to [__]
them.
Sorry. Anyone else is an LPOTL fan? But those three guys all
have super hot wives and joke about how they're out of their
league, but it's because humor and personality matter a lot when
it comes to being attracted to someone." And Fenwick and Charlie
Okay, hold on. Hold on. Hold on.
Last Podcast on the Left Cast. These three guys. Like Okay, this
guy is
Are we really pretending we're working the same league here?
This guy's kind of goofy-looking, but
Dude, really? We're going to pretend we're on the We're going
to pretend we're in the same dimensions here?
Come on, man.
Come on, man. Come on, man. Come on, dog. And Clarka says, "Right?
He's funny and charismatic, clever, has three dogs, he holds
down a full-time job, and he streams. Seems like a high-value
male to me." And Felicity Foxen says, "That's husband material
to me." And private message me Anisa's photos replies, "There's
just something about a New York Italian that's just yes, please."
Then unrelated, there was another tweet
you you, Connor. You, Connor.
You. You. You. That went viral of someone I didn't realize it
was going to be me again the whole episode. photoshopping themselves
with AI and a girl. And J Talk quote tweeted this post and instead
photoshopped Anisa and Nicholas DeOro with AI and a caption,
"This could be us. Look how
happy you look." And Neo Slacker replies, "Her hands on his soft
midsection has me [__] rolling." Anisa then replies
to this image by saying, "Dude, I can't And Anisa Why is this
on my timeline?
I'm being included for the worst snarking I've ever done. [__]
my to block you. No, you." And Scott replies, "You hate having
the most dangerous and baddest [__] in the game.
You should drop [laughter] that creepy loser who refuses to keep
you in line
This guy made me up with a king like this." And Anisa replies
with a emoji and a piss emoji. She then also says, "I can't stop
laughing. I should have never tweeted about this freak. My timeline
has been ruined. My god." You then tweets out this clip with
the caption, "Nicholas DeOro responds after Anisa called him
out on the timeline." Saying that privated by Instagram over
this drama. Like I've now privated by Instagram. Not true. My
Instagram was privated during the doxing drama that the people
who are mad about this tried to say didn't happen during the
Turkey Tom situation. Uh my Instagram's been privated for
Oh, he's still going to run with that anyway even though he came
here and
And the second that they presented something that was credible,
we went, "Oh yeah, no, that that seems concerning." Dude, do
we not Dude, of course he's going to rewrite it that way. What
a loser, man.
The second we're like, "Hey, you haven't proven this out at all.
Like nothing you are saying actually lines up with what you've
posted." And then eventually we go through the thread. I have
to reverse go through the thread and find and make the argument
for them. And then when I do that, me and Queenie are both like,
"Yeah, I guess it's Yeah, no, it makes sense. No, it does seem
like she's trying to dox somebody. It's pretty [__]
up, man." The second we saw the information, we flipped. For
over a month, I was considering unprivating privating it, but
I don't use it enough to really justify it being a public platform.
Um then Anisa said, "Bro's ankles, dude. Look at these ankles.
Look like they've been pumped with salts, and he needs a lymph-
lymphatic drainage stat. He looks like he has a rotation of goods."
Yeah, I got a rotation of goods. Uh that are all beige in color.
I guess that means foods. She had the ability to edit this, I
think. That's not my problem. Micronutrients matter. Love your
body. Take a multivitamin. So, it wasn't a multivitamin. I just
lost 100 lb. That that kind of cleared up the whole leg thing,
but I appreciate your courtesy. And listen, all right? You can
lose weight. You can regrow your hair, you know? If you really
Listen, I think around the time this photo was taken, you were
like a bald little boy, right? Because you you got Pipo sad and
shaved your head like Britney Spears. Wasn't that what you were
doing? This is I wish I was pretty. Oh, I wish I felt pretty.
It wasn't I wish I was pretty. I wish I felt pretty. Yeah, but
I mean the reality of the situation is you can lose some weight.
I need to lose some weight. I'm still a person of calorie. And
you can regrow your hair. I think it looks fine now,
the tattoos the tattoos are here
Really? That doesn't work. That works when somebody's like
right? You can do You can do that argument when you're like ugly,
okay? Or sorry, when the other person is like ugly. You'd be
like, "Well, I could lose weight, but you're always going to
have that face. But The the problem is Anisa is not
is not that. You can lose some Dude, bro, she's got like You
You got people sad and shaved your head like Britney Spears.
Wasn't that what you You were going to Okay, I This is I wish
I was pretty. I wish I felt pretty. It wasn't I wish I Could
she Could she lose that much weight here? Is he really saying
that she could lose weight here? What part of this is like, oh,
she could lose She could stand to lose Hey, toots, you could
stand to lose a few pounds.
Is she
was pretty. I wish I felt pretty. Yeah, but I mean the reality
of the situation is you could lose some weight. I need to lose
some weight. I'm still a person of calorie and you can regrow
She's not ugly, but she may actively makes herself look worse.
Well, I mean shaving your head looks worse. But you could also
just wear wigs.
I The tattoos unfortunately work with the whole aesthetic. >> I
think it looks Like I hate them personally, but for the people
who like that aesthetic, the tattoos work, right? Fine now, but
the tattoos The tattoos are here >> doodles from Miles
Morales's notebook. >> THIS IS AWFUL. IT IS. If you sue
the person who gave you the tattoos for damages, then I think
that Ethan would fund the lawsuit. That would be based. I don't
like this woman. The The The >> You spent all of iDubbbz's
money on buying boobs, de-boobing them, and filling your body
with the ugliest tattoos anyone's ever seen in their lives. Remember,
weight could be lost, hair could be grown back, but your body
is ravaged forever. Anyway, I think we have one
>> Now say the BIT ABOUT HER EGGS. TALK ABOUT HOW HER EGGS
are gone, Nicholas. Nicholas, talk about how her eggs are are
leaving her body rapidly.
Tell her she's on a timer.
Show her the clock, NICHOLAS. NOW. >> THING to check out
here. Oh, yeah, that's the other part. Dude, you know who caught
the biggest stray in this entire drama? This is like the Keemstar
thing where she found out that everyone thinks she's ugly. Frogan
just found out that all of her friends think that she's disgusting.
That's the funniest part of this entire drama.
Okay, I got to I just got to say it. Is it not crazy that Frogan
and Stardust are on the exact same arc? Is Does he include the
Frogan [__] in here?
Are there the pictures with Frogan? Bro, Frogan was like posting
selfies of herself, and she's like lost weight, but she's not
like down. And it's like the same as Stardust where they both
like lost weight, but it's like, dude, I get I get what you're
going for,
but you guys need to just chill for a little bit, okay?
There's other things to sort out a little bit. Just a little
bit, okay? Just a little bit.
Now, if you're comparing to Nicholas, you're probably way better
off, but >> literally Guys, I've been getting called fat
for 7 years, but Frogan just found out that all of her friends
think she's
I watched that clip of DeOro,
and Augie and Tom are joking about being like Stewie following
him with the tuba cuz he's that fat.
I've never seen Bro, I couldn't imagine.
I couldn't imagine that level of like snark from your
Holy That's the funniest [__] ever. I didn't I didn't
know the tuba bit. I didn't know the bit from Family Guy. Somebody
linked it in the chat. They're like, oh, they're referencing
this bit. I'm like, oh my god. And it fits Nicholas perfectly.
Literally the way Nicholas waddles in that clip fits the Stewie
Griffin Family Guy thing so perfectly, it's
That is actually the funniest take is that everybody legitimately
Like she found out yesterday that all of her friends think she's
And Proxy replies again with the sleepy clip we looked at earlier
on the friend zoning. And Kong is among us replies, "Go Go quick,
he's flaming her. Bring out the 2019 files." And you are our
world's tour set.
>> This An anime avatar that thinks being friend zoned
in 2019 is some big exposé. Yeah, that tracks. Nightkitten says,
"Damn, I hate DeOro, but everyone he beefs with is a two chronically
wrong in How did they [__] up his Insta being privated
that far back?" Reegis and Philbin says, "He loves to say, well,
I can lose the weight, but he never loses the weight." And Betty
Plutonium says, "He just lost 100 lb." And Reegis says, "I consider
losing the weight
Oh, dude.
That's [clears throat] rough.
He just lost 100 lb.
That's why he won't cam up cuz he's lost 100 lb. And if he cams
up, it's going to be
He was at the size where like it's not going to be readily obvious
he lost weight. That's [__] up. He doesn't no longer
being disgustingly obese, which he has not done. It's the Frogan
tweet, okay?
I've spoken up against the mean
Oh, jeez, this is today. This is today? I didn't know there was
more stuff from today. I didn't look at any of this. Girl with
a microphone, Glam tweets, claims she's defended Frogan, then
attacks her for going after DeOro's weight. I think it's wild
for someone who's been body shamed online for so many years to
turn around and use that. But I think she's immature.
What? people say about Frogan's looks and she went at Nick so
fast. Yeah, I've I've defended Frogan, too. And I I mean, I can't
say
I can't say I'm surprised that Frogan went after Nick at all.
I think it's wild.
I will say, okay, if I had to predict I This going to sound crazy
cuz I don't think she's like I It's no comment on who she is
as a as a person,
but I think that Frogan has the facial features where if she
did lose a bunch of weight, she could potentially be like
I think.
I can't say that for 100% certainty until I see her lose the
weight, but I do think if she like lost the weight, she might
have the facial features to be
Like it might be stark for people.
I think that's
I'm pretty sure that's true, okay? I'm pretty sure. >> for
somebody who has been body shamed online for so many years to
turn around and use that, but I think she's immature. I think
she's immature just like all of her friends. So, I'm not
Like, "Ooh, you're fatter than me." Like
Girl, what are we doing? What are we doing? She looks 45% 45%
better that new picture she posted.
The hijab sucks, man. The hijab really sucks for this stuff.
She's always going to look like Jeffrey the Killer or whatever
with the hijab,
It's BS. Are you lean maxing, though? I respect the grind. Trying
to.
I support your ambitions, grind stairmaster. It's worth it.
Wow. Wow. Wow.
Sleepy, you guys ever see
Is it How I Met Your Mother?
>> Where where
Neil Patrick Harris's character, he like goes to the gym and
and just like tries to talk up all the fat women and he calls
it investing. He's like, yeah, look, all these women are trying
to get They're trying to get lean. They're like 6 months away
from being hot, and who's there when they first want to hit the
dating market again? It's this guy. Is that what Sleepy's doing
here? Is Is Sleepy doing that? Is he investing right now in Frogan's
future?
An ambitious play.
Very interesting. Okay. Chud Logic reacts to a Reddit post of
H3 Y moms thirsting over DeOro. This is like pity Oh, I won't
Let's watch it. >> Right? He's He's funny, charismatic,
clever, has three dogs, holds down a full-time job, and streams.
Seems like a high-value male to me. This This is
like pity. This is Okay, let's see if we hit the same thing,
right?
This is literally the exact same tone and tenor as Ethan Klein
going Bip bop boop bop. That doesn't even sound like Hila. Me
minor. I'm a big fan of Nicholas DeOro. I'm a big fan of Nicholas
DeOro. It's the exact same thing, right? You just totally disconnect
from reality to make some asinine comment,
right? That's like the same thing happening here. It's catching
on in that
That doesn't Who does that even sound like? That's supposed to
be Hila? What? No way.
Oh my god, he's like
>> SEEMS LIKE A HIGH-VALUE male to me. Right? This is like
These people are saying this because they feel sorry for him
and want to try and like hope he sees this and boost him up a
bit. This is not real. This is not genuine expressions of like
>> Okay, hold on. Another Conspiracy Leamer
hair in a bun 2 days. >> Glam responds Girl with a microphone
responds to the bun allegations while refusing to say Anisa's
name. Suddenly I don't love myself. I'm a ugly slob. My bun is
full of mold. >> What? And suddenly I don't care for myself.
Suddenly I don't love myself. I'm I'm a ugly slob. And my bun
is full of mold, someone said. Like it's just that you
Buns are a problem. Literally everyone I know wears a bun a lot
of days in a in a
It's like they make the most innocuous
into a problem. It is like an abusive partner. Exactly.
>> I will say just facially the symmetry between her and
DeOro is really funny to me. Okay, it's just really funny.
They look unironically like they they they are related.
Unironically like they're related, okay?
into a problem. It is like an abusive partner. Exactly.
>> Hyper hyper hypercritical. It's so dumb. They all I
Most of them probably if they're if they are women or people
with long hair, many of them probably wear buns. Like that's
the thing, it's
disingenuous. It's completely disingenuous. Wow.
Wow. People who hate me are kind of like abusive. Like they say
really mean things like an abusive partner who hates
Yeah, they they hate you. That's what That's what they're doing.
Hila sunset linking this post again. You're a
He just keeps linking the same post of Glam with this Popeyes
chicken wing. He just keeps He's linked this post like five times.
He just keeps posting it over and over again. Look, it's Glam
with the chicken wing. Look, it's Glam with the chicken wing.
Or a drumstick, maybe. I can't tell. Maybe it looks like a chicken
wing. It's a I think it's a drumette, but it's actually drumstick.
Yeah, hold on. Aide. The girl with the moral authority and stuff
These are Nick's new boys, by the way. The the
I don't even know who else. These are Nick's new boys, okay?
This is the new cabal.
is now
an ally. New cabal qualifications. You need to have shown that
you that you have had the capability to eat 10,000 calories in
a day. We got Guam. We got Harley. We don't know who else we
got. Okay, we got Guam, we got Harley, and I can't say beyond
that. But if you've been able to consume 10,000 calories in a
day, you might be on the ticket, guys. You could join the new
cabal.
of Nicholas Deorio.
Is this really what he wants?
He wants this dumb ugly to come out and defend him, really? Oh,
wow. More fat phobia from moral authority Anisa Jomar. What a
cool and interesting person she is. Okay, I know Listen, I know
that people say I'm coping about this. I know people say I know
the snarkers say I'm coping about this,
This is not the same dude. Is he going to say that Nick lost
a lot of weight? >> the same guy that I used to know. It
is not.
It is not, dude. Oh, he's coping that he's way different
>> Dude, that almost got a That almost got a legitimate
Tucker laugh out of me.
>> Okay, I just Dude, there's no way he's still on this.
No, no, no. He's really changed, guys. He's like changed so much.
>> loser coming out who's even more, if it's even possible,
even more of an Ethan Klein dick suck
than Nicholas is. Mhm. >> Fat phobia, really? Is that what
What the [__] Fat phobia. Fat phobia. I'll be honest,
am I crazy or is am I crazy or is Chud's like heart not in it?
Chud's like trying to snark
on Nick, and his heart I could just tell his heart isn't in it.
Not even a little
Am I the only one who could just see it? That Chud's really not
He's like kind of He's like going through the motions. He just
He's not in it.
He still loves Nicholas Deorio. It's [__] up.
Nick H3 Waiting Room Deorio is calling the controversy where
he posted a picture of his hand touching a woman's hand, who
then publicly denied any intimate relationship with Pigalus,
the fake friend zone allegation, in response to Anisa snarking
him. >> then Anisa came for your boy. We saw
after me. This is a funny one, because this is the Nicholas Deorio
fake friend zone allegation from like Is this 2020 Is this 6
years ago or 7 years ago? I forgot. We've gone through this so
many times. The last time the fake friend zone allegations came
up, I believe it was it was DarkViperAU
last year where we had to address it. Guys, guys, listen.
DarkViperAU
brought this up. That's why you shouldn't pay any attention.
It's fake, and we addressed it back then when DarkViperAU,
thoroughly discredited person, DarkViperAU.
That's the last time we address it. Okay, what's the response?
No, we were dating? What was the response? >> link this
to you. If you want to watch um me explain this entire situation,
I sent it to somebody inherently more uh put together than I
am. >> watch this? So you can check it out. Does anyone
have this? It's just man, it's just what a part of being an adult
is. Like we're ripping talking points from Mr. Viper Australia.
All right, then Anisa came for your boy. They they went after
me.
Bro, there are people um this happened when I used to stream
with other people. There are people who just show up and they're
like, "Oh, the person you stream with isn't here at all? Well,
awesome." I'm just like, "Why do you feel the need to verbalize
this?" I'll just be real, that's like very likely to just get
you banned at some point. It just annoys me.
It's basically like the same as asking me to switch the content.
If you ever come in and verbalize that like while I'm watching
chat, you just get vaporized, okay? Very annoying to me. All
right, all right, hold on. We have more. There is more. I do
want to watch the DarkViperAU video, though.
Hour 24, DarkViperAU's dishonesty exposed. Real quick from the
top. He posted a picture of him with a girl to insinuate that
he had a girlfriend. >> I posted a picture of drinks during
COVID, and there was a girl's hand in the frame. There's no Like
it's already just insane cope. It's already just totally insane
cope. Is he going to show the full picture
Or is he just going to show this like smaller version? Cuz I'm
pretty sure you see both hands in the full version, right? Like
if you click the to maximize
I'm pretty sure you see both hands. >> caption here insinuating
that I was trying to make this grandiose statement about who
this girl was or that she was my girlfriend.
Okay, why are we pretending
that there's not a clear inference you would make from that picture?
There's no way that he's like, "Guys, if you want to see this
addressed, go watch me cope over here. Yeah, there's just no
real reason for you to expect that to be my girlfriend. What
if that was my mom?"
That's a weird picture to post if it's your mom. That's like
a weird picture to post in general for a man. It's a very effeminate
picture to post, okay?
I'm shocked a man posted that picture in the first place, to
tell you the truth.
But beyond that, what It's clearly it's a clear inference when
you have your hands super close together on the drinks like that.
What's going on, man? >> And the girl comes and like I
mean he says, "Haha, we're just friends." This is in response
to some random guy asking if that's my girlfriend. Not me, not
my post, some guy's question. So that isn't the girl? Or why
is it blocked out? If that's just a random person, if that's
not the girl, why is her name blocked out? Why?
Why is her name blocked out like this?
If this is If it's not real,
what And why does this matter? Huh, actually it was just a random
dude who said this, and it wasn't me.
So wait, is the Is his debunking of the fake friend zone allegation
that he posted a picture, and it was just meant to be like, "Oh,
look at me and my bestie out getting drinks." And so he never
implied that they were dating, so her her explicitly saying they
aren't dating isn't being friend zoned. Does he not realize that's
not what people are laughing at? Like people would laugh at this
no matter what,
It's It's funny in either case, right?
It doesn't matter what It doesn't matter what his post was. It's
a girl who went out of her way to dox herself on the internet,
right? To put herself out there in spheres you operate in, just
to be like, "We aren't dating. We aren't dating. No. No, we're
not
We're not dating. That's it. That's a cringe clarification, no
matter where it happens, okay? No matter who brings it that is
a cringe
Ralph Wiggum, you can see the moment his heart rips in half,
moment, okay?
That's a guy asking if that's my girlfriend. Not me, not my post,
some guy's question. And the girl comes and like I mean he says,
"Haha, we're just friends." And so people widely mocked him cuz
he tried to pretend to actually um be in a relationship or whatever.
And the funniest part of this entire situation is the person
who's in this message, the person who we're talking about, is
literally my ex-girlfriend from high school and college. Somebody
that I had an on-again, off-again relationship with for probably
between 5 and 6 years at the time this tweet was even posted.
But that's totally irrelevant. This could be a platonic friend.
Even if that was the case. >> He posted a picture of him
with a girl to insinuate that he had a girlfriend.
I figured it was somebody he dated. If they weren't dating at
the time, it is a little weird. I'll be I'll be honest, it's
a little weird. It might be weirder knowing it was an on-again,
off-again relationship. Cuz again, it's pretty obvious what the
inference is for anybody looking at the picture,
and then she comes in and just clarifies
Does she not Would she not have a great idea of what you do and
who you hang around with? Like that you're constantly talking
to like sector adjacent guys, people who do doxing and [__]
Would she really Would she really wanted to like put herself
out there just to be like, "Haha, we're not dating,
The framing of this allegation is completely ridiculous. And
so people widely mocked him cuz he tried to pretend to um be
in a relationship or whatever. It's actually hilarious that Dark
Viper is totally cool with signal boosting completely false allegations
against me, which up until this point
>> Like he's calling him
HE'S SIGNAL BOOSTING FALSE ALLEGATIONS AGAINST DUDE, it's The
false allegation is that you're cringe. You're a cringe
I'm sorry. Whether or not that's false or what It doesn't matter.
Bro,
only repeated by extremely stupid smaller chat. I mean this is
a massive YouTuber to be regurgitating this to his audience.
Bro, he's actually sitting here pretending
He's actually sitting here pretending that this is like a rape
allegation.
He's pre- He's pretending it's on like the same level as a rape
Not I I'm not even exaggerating. We can hear it in his voice.
This guy's sitting here propagating false allegations about me.
He's not even a small channel. It's only Well, this is only repeated
by the dumbest the smallest and dumbest channels.
Dude, what? An entire support group of these drama creators who
do not care if what they're saying is true. By the way, more
proof that he was always like this, just for Chud who's still
coping. If anybody needs to send this to Chud so he can understand
that he's just coping, watch this section of this video. This
dude always been like this, okay? Always.
They're just trying to make videos as false as possible. But
it's even funnier knowing that the guy who literally is claiming
to be in danger and blaming us for himself getting doxxed is
the one that's doing this. Now, I've tried not to react this.
I really have. I've tried to make as few statements on this as
humanly possible because every time I talk about it, I put this
person in danger of people looking into them and finding things
about them. There's a clip of
Like, I'm pretty sure this girl is just like massive.
Nicholas, whenever this girl is brought up, Nicholas pretends
that you're like you're about to like dox and kill her for bringing
her up. She posted publicly on Twitter. She's all censored and
This girl is just like very, very, very embarrassing to look
at, I think. That has to be what it is. I don't see any other
possibility cuz size-wise, right? It has to be It has to be the
case
like she clearly didn't mind identifying herself online. She's
not a private person. If that's cuz I assume that Sacramento
is talking about the same person. Sacramento said that Nick knew
this girl forever, that they were like on-again, off-again for
years and years and years.
It's the same person. A person who is known online apparently
at one point.
No? Would these not be the same person? They seem like they're
obviously the same person. I I don't think anybody should go
look her up or anything. I'm just saying that she clearly was
somebody who had made her identity known online in some way.
of me freaking out about it and I'm not thinking of oh my god,
this looks bad for me. It's a meme among all my IRL friends that
the internet thinks I got friend-zoned by somebody who I've been
seeing for way too long over the years.
>> But like, I'm worried about that person's anonymity.
I'm worried about that person being the star of several videos
and several streams which is a
why weren't they concerned about their anonymity? Exactly what
happened to DarkViper's girlfriend. Oh.
Oh, I wait Oh my god, wait. Oh Oh guys, it makes so much sense
now why he picked that one in particular. It's because his [__]
girlfriend got doxxed because he was bragging because Carl Job
said that he was a [__] girlfriendless loser. That's
why this is here. You don't really You have nobody realizes why
he picked this one? Let it play. In fact, the person that What's
the allegation? >> before filmed an entire fake interview
with a random woman pretending to be my ex-girlfriend. But That's
not funny. That is not funny, Salvo. What the
What the It's only funny and the only reason we're really talking
about it right now is because this is DarkViper, somebody who
literally posts his girlfriend on Instagram uh just to prove
he has one. Every insecurity he's trying to project onto me is
one that he absolutely has and absolutely possesses and I think
that's really
I'm I'm sorry.
onto me. >> that girl cuz that girl is like That girl is
like significantly more attractive than him. He's like psyched.
It's not just he has a girlfriend. I'm sure he can get a girlfriend.
>> he absolutely has and absolutely It's just like she's
hot. That's why he's posting her a lot. >> absolutely possesses
and I think that's
Also, I don't know if you guys know Women tend to like when you
make social posts with them.
That's just a thing they like. He is the That it's like you're
making it clear you are dating somebody, you like them. It's
like very fulfilling for them. >> the type of person who
will post a picture with a girl just so the internet knows that
he has a girlfriend. That is him. That's why he's saying this.
This is something he literally would do. Funny that you would
go and attack somebody without doing any research at all whatsoever
and make a claim like this knowing how you feel about Oh, that
That's a less good picture of her. >> your current situation
with your current partner. So, I'm trying to tack into this video
stuff that I don't think is going to come up in the next video.
I want to showcase how brazenly these guys lie and how low their
standard of >> is funny. Watch this. >> just Willy
MacShow. It's not just Chad Logic. It's an entire support group
of these drama creators who do not care if what they're saying
is true. Funny story, this was supposed to be a response to just
this one little
I think it's so funny.
Bro, the the meltdown.
THIS GUY IS MAKING FALSE ALLEGATIONS about me. That's By the
way, are basically true.
Like that I'm sorry. The fact that you might have dated this
girl before this and weren't dating here, it is still the obvious
implication from this picture and she had to come out and correct
it. I don't know, man. Uh it's very goofy. It's all very goofy,
but
whatever. Um
Okay, we're back to the
Oh, the Twitter clips. We're on Twitter stuff here. Hold on.
We're over on this clip. We watched the DarkViper80 thing. Okay,
we're good to go. Next tweets. Conspiracy Lemur again. Let's
go. Good. Chad Logic declares Anisa won versus the Oreo. Anisa
won. People are so set in their mindset with stuff they that
they just can't admit that and accept it. It's literally the
meme. Here's some embarrassing information about me. Please don't
mock me for it. But you know, it's it's quite embarrassing. It's
quite embarrassing And no matter which way you slice it and no
matter which way you try and, you cope or sweep. Like having
this not only brought up again and sent around on
but also having [__] Anisa the [__] thing.
>> Like Anisa's won this. Anisa's won. That's it. Anisa's
won. And that's it. It's that's the end. Like quote tweeting
some embarrassing clip of you saying this is embarrassing. You're
just kind of right. And that's that
Like what else do you even say to this? What else do you even,
you know, I can see why Nicholas doesn't want to accept this
frame. This puts him back in high school, okay? The hot girl
is just laughing and just pointing and laughing at you and your
general existence.
Like what do you even do You There's no way to win.
She's hot. She's pointing and laughing at you and she's just
giggling at your existence. What the [__] are you
going to do now, Nick? It's just like There's just nothing else
to be done. It's over.
>> And the thing is, people Dude, this is the issue, bro.
This is the issue.
are so set in their kind of mindset with this stuff that they
can't just admit that and they can't accept it. You know what
I mean? Like they can't go Oh, [__] no. You just
kind of got him there. It is
It is [__] embarrassing at the end of the day. And
she's right, it is.
And the thing is, even if it's a [__] old clip, whatever,
it doesn't matter. It's still embarrassing. And also, another
thing that some people aren't willing to engage with is that
how do you rationalize
this idea that it's wrong to have yourself spoken about
and yet, you know, and yet on the other hand, you can speak about
other people's relationships. It's like it's fair game if you
put a picture on the internet that people are going to mock it,
talk about it, whatever they want to do with it. It's literally
the meme. Here's some embarrassing information about me. You
know what is it? I'm a sociopathic [__] Here's some
embarrassing information about me. You know, please don't mock
me for it. >> That's wonderful. But how do I make money
off depressed people? Okay. Wow. All right. I am looking for
What are we looking for next? We've got two more clips here.
Oh wait, one last tweet on this specific thing.
Queen of Points Out How Dory Refuses to Help @GlamTweets Fight
the Evil Snarkers. You know, Glam is beyond help because Nick
does not even attempt to stick his neck out for her. You might
see Nick step out for Harley, but never for Glam. Oh, this is
so true. That
Nick would never want to associate in the opposite direction
and go after people for Glam and he will never do it in like
a in a temporally like relevant way. He'll He'll never do it
right here like at this time, right?
He'll never step in and try to fight one of these people.
He'll let it pass and maybe he'll go over Maybe he'll like tear
them apart the next day,
but he never wants to be accused of simping for Glam. He is so
It's so radioactive to him, the idea that they look alike and
people are going to mock him for it. He He just won't let that
that bond that image form between them, okay? He can't have it.
It is total cancer for his brand. He does not want that attachment
whatsoever. >> it was legit. You know
Glam is just like beyond help because Nick does not even attempt
to stick his neck out for her. You know, How would you tell?
>> You might even see Nick The Queen might just stick his
neck out as you know, you might He Oh, he did a little He did
a little, you know, you know, he like pointed with his chin.
I thought that was just Canadian Native Americans who did that.
Yeah, it's over there. It's over there. You guys don't even know
what I'm talking about, but it's a funny joke if you get it,
okay?
Natives in Canada do that [__] all the time. They
point like with their their chin and their lips. Over there.
I'm doing it, but you can't see me. So, too bad. You
you know, you might even see Nick slightly step out for Harley
once in a while, but never for Glam. Never for Glam.
Another woman's hair and And how it was
I get why he's terrified of it. I get I do get it. Sweeping for
Nick having a neck. Damn.